[Music]
how do I support my husband while he
Grieves losing his job and navigating
constant rejection while finding a new
one but still holding him accountable to
getting a job and not making excuses for
all the reasons why he can't do certain
[Music]
things what in the world is going on
this is John with the Dr John delone
show a show where we talk about your
mental health your emotional health your
family your kids whatever you got going
on in your
life when things get hard things get
scary when things get frustrating or you
just get
enraged my promises I'll sit with you
and we're going to figure out what to do
next I've been doing this for more than
two decades sitting with hurting people
trying to figure out what are we going
to do next and if you want to be on the
show we talk about your marriage talk
about your spouse we can talk about you
talk about your family we can talk about
whatever you got going on your mental
health Diagnostics whatever you got if
you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at1 1844 693
3291 or go to john.com
askas and the show comes out a couple of
days after Christmas which means we are
right up against New Year's my favorite
time of the year my favorite time of the
year I love New Year's cuz we all get to
say ah this didn't work last year or we
should probably work on this a little
bit more and make some resolutions I
know resolutions fail a lot I know I
know but I love them I love them I love
reflection I love sitting in the woods
and trying to figure out huh I love
sitting with my wife as we do our annual
planning Retreat and say how did last
year go do we meet our financial goals
what's the state of our marriage what's
we've never been parents of a eighth
grader before we've never been parents
of a whatever before we've never had a
parent in the hospital we've never had
whatever is going on and we get to plan
at least with our limited foresight
what's going to come next year I love
New Year's and that's why I created
questions for humans the New Year's
edition if you order them today they may
be there by New Year's it may be too
late it may be too late but and they may
be sold out by the time they get here
usually they sell out but um let's give
it a shot Kelly let's run through a
couple of New Year's questions all right
by the way this is my favorite deck I
think the New Year's ones the New Year
the questions are just fantastic yeah
it's my favorite all right what's one
person you want to spend more time with
next year and
why so you don't have to say me that's
fine I get
it dude you just got to know the joke I
had that just came right to my mind that
I didn't say I'm so proud of you
whenever you put in your weekly reports
like I work with such an immature [__]
I want you to know I'm getting more
mature I'm
practicing um golly I want to spend more
time with my wife I just love hanging
out with her um I want to spend more
intentional time with friends I really
um didn't do that well this year it was
pretty rough I got some great guys like
Andre live in my neighborhood like I
just I just sucked at it this year I was
on the road I was traveling so this year
um not one person but a group of guys a
group a gang I need a
gang what about you I'm my husband uh
we're going through some well as you
know cuz you and I have talked we're
going through some stuff right now and
we are working on as we talk about
blowing it up rebuilding it and part of
that is um you know with our daughter
and the special needs with a lot of
stress in our house and we don't spend
any time I mean we don't get to we don't
go out we don't go on vacations alone
because we don't have that option right
now yeah and we so we need to be more
intentional about it so that's my goal
is not just more time in the house doing
things but more time of he and I that's
awesome yeah and then for those of you
listening so when you ask answer a
question like that like I want to have
more time with my friends I want to have
more time with my husband
then the challenge becomes okay I'm
going to clear my calendar I'm going to
take my arm and wipe it across the
calendar and say this comes first then
how do I make this a possibility and
nothing else gives right otherwise life
just gets in the way so that's very cool
all right what's another one all right
what are two words that you would use to
sum up this year and please don't say
dumpster fire oh
man truly remarkable was how I would how
I would describe this year
like the truly remarkable um profession
like the show continues this doubled in
size it's just every month I feel like
we get the reports back and it's bigger
than it's just growing at a rate that's
so I can't wrap my head around it um had
a number another number one W Street
Journal bessling book and um we had a
good year financially Sheila and I so I
mean like just really remarkable but
then more importantly marriage was hard
and then it got amazing and then it was
harder again and then it got amazing and
I'd never been a parent of an eighth
grader I've read about it and I've
worked with eighth graders I never had
one in my house and so it's just been
and and same with the second grade it's
just been really remarkable TR
remarkable uh mine would be opposite
ends if I'm putting two words there
because I thought you were G to say
really sucky no no because I really
actually originally I was going to say
very hard but um there's been especially
workwise because you talked about the
show it's been like the best year ever
work-wise it's wild I mean we've had
huge growth of the show and so that's
been fantastic but we've also walked
through probably the hardest things
we've ever done with uh you know losing
parents L the house and some issues
we're dealing with it's it's been an
incredibly incredibly hard year um but
also you know as they all are there's
good and there's bad yeah so yeah very
cool man go to uh john.com pick up
questions for humans and I'm telling you
if you do this with just one person it's
amazing and if you do it with four or
five people and you get to say some of
these things out loud and experience
other people saying them and you don't
just wait for your turn to speak like
they talk about in Fight Club but you
actually listen and go wow I didn't
think about that they are transformative
for your nervous system for your body
for your relationships for everything go
pick them up all right let's go out to
Tampa Florida and talk to an hey Ann
what's
up can you hear me I hi I can hear you
up not too much how are you good good
good good what's up in your
world okay so my question is um how do I
support my husband while he Grieves
losing his job and navigating constant
rejection while finding a new one but
still holding him accountable to getting
a job and not making excuses for all the
reasons why he can't do certain things o
that one's that's tough um let's start
at the back end of the question and work
the other way um okay for you to say the
words I need to hold him
accountable tell me about that I think I
know where you're going but I want to
hear you say it well it just seems like
he's trying to find work I know he's
trying but he's maybe not trying as hard
as I think he could or maybe in the ways
I think he should be um
and it's always kind of like well you
know I'm not going to apply for that one
because well the hours are not great or
it doesn't work
or the pay isn't enough you know it's
always just kind of something or I I had
one it was like well they want me to do
this project and I'm not gonna do this
project before I have a job you know
it's kind of like excuses and then it
Narrows his his his you know
applications and and so I'm kind of like
well you know what you're doing isn't
working so so let's try something else
but I also know he's he's really
struggling right it it's it's hard it's
been hard for him and the more rejection
right the harder it is so I'm kind of
trying to navigate you know hold pushing
him but understanding that it's hard oh
man um I've got some probably
controversial thoughts on this topic but
I'm just going to speak directly I don't
have a lot of literature on this I'm
going to speak directly from my guts
okay okay um first off while you're
talking it reminded me of uh there's
that scene in Dumb and Dumber when it's
like there's no jobs out there and I
think it's Lloyd Christmas goes yeah
unless you want to work 40 hours a
week all right so
exactly um do you have kids by the way
yes we have two kids in daycare so we
both work fulltime so the kids are still
in daycare so is he is he have some sort
of just Band-Aid job right now or is he
just sitting at home applying just
sitting at home applying he's he's try
tried to sign up for like instacart and
Uber and all of that and they're all all
the weight lists are full um he did do
like one cat sitting right um okay so
here okay I I wish he was on the phone
he's not so you're GNA feel some of the
smoke from me and it's not aimed at you
okay it's aimed at men in America how
about that um I remember as a young kid
I was at a church um that was I'd say
somewhat of an affluent Church before
fluent churches were were a thing um in
my neighborhood growing up it was just a
neighborhood church but it was pretty
big and people did pretty well and I
remember there was a
man who got fired from his executive
job and he asked for a meeting with the
Elders of the church on Sunday
afternoon and by Monday they had fired
their custodial staff and this former
executive was cleaning the toilets at
the church and emptying waste
baskets mhm and I remember a couple
years later I got out of college and I
was a high school teacher and we had
this uh I was driving through town and
as I was pulling into to get sign my HR
paperwork of this I was going to be a
teacher now a high school teacher I
actually saw him driving out and I saw a
sign in the yard and it was like a open
day basically it was like a job fair
MH and I remember thinking
this is what masculinity looks like this
man will do anything to pay the light
bill and the water bill and put food on
his
table and it was the most like I'm so
glad I got to see that both up close
like just my dad worked at the church
after we quit being a police officer and
I saw I'd be up there just messing
around in his office and I'd see this
guy walking through in jeans in a dress
shirt cleaning toilets empty in trash
and I know he was applying like crazy
but the job market was a mess especially
for executives and his thing he did and
then he went and got a job as a
teacher
right he went and got a job and I was
driving in rural Tennessee the other day
taking my daughter to breakfast and I
saw a sign the McDonald's was $20 an
hour M 20 bucks an
hour um almost every store down the way
had jobs open
and now since applications all even give
people a pass in old days that you had
to wait right you had to try to catch
somebody during the
day now I can work two full-time fast
food jobs and making $20 an hour and
maybe not where you live so maybe $15 an
hour although I bet it's more in Tampa
you can work and then all night after
the kids are in bed you can apply for
jobs apply for jobs apply for
jobs M and I'm going to I say something
that's unpopular because I talk about
grief all the time he doesn't have time
for that in this moment m i remember one
of my close friends um her husband was
just a dead beat packed up and left her
pregnant with child number
three and I remember asking her how are
you doing this and she said I don't know
but I don't have that option to
not right y we will figure this out I
have two children staring at me saying
mommy hungry and I have a third one
about to be born mhm so there was a
season a time for grief it wasn't when
that that dead beat packed up and took
off because those babies had to
eat so I think right now the
conversation has to shift from you get a
season of mourning and let's be sad
about the loss of a job dude the data is
clear a job loss especially for somebody
who has identified a career as an
identity like I'm a dentist I am an
attorney I'm a executive whatever is
similar to um losing a loved one it's
really it's it's hard on your body it's
hard on your mind it's hard on your
identity it's hard on everything and
then you got to go get a freaking job
because our family needs
money right and so I have
zero zero compassion in this
moment none zero okay you go find
work and I know that's easy for me to
say that's really difficult for you
isn't
it because you're in the house with him
right right and you have to navigate the
mood swings and oh my gosh and this is
just not GNA be a good fit for us and
what right and by the way you're getting
up and going to work every day right
right and this is when the resentment
starts to slowly creep in right
and then intimacy becomes hard because
respect is hard and competency
competency is hard like all of it just
works together right right
yep so what have you tried so far that
has not worked or did some big thing
happen and that's why you called or is
this just this dripping ongoing no it's
it's just been ongoing yeah it's just
been how long and I told him it has been
seven
months and I told him at the time he got
Severance right so he had a couple
months and we we you know we're debt
free we have our we have a ton of money
and savings so we're fine but I told
them I said there's going to come a
point where you get any job or the kids
are going to stay home you're you're now
full-time dad right because of the cost
of daycare absolutely um and he he says
he understand and all that and I know
he's you know he's trying he's at that
point where he's trying to get those
like gig jobs right but but it's the
it's just kind of I feel like excuses
right or on a weight list on a weight
list million percent 1 million
percent right throw the gig jobs out the
window you know why he wants a gig job
because he can hide right go put on a
visor and serve Burger
King yeah it's a noble job you're
helping people
eat and more than that it's a noble job
because you're showing your kids what it
looks like to get hit in the mouth and
get back up
right and so if I'm you I would have a
conversation it'd be a hard one but
again not not at home but sitting down
saying okay this going be a hard
conversation and you're going to want to
duck out I need you to stay with me will
you stay with me and he'll say yes I
love you I want to be married to you
here's where we are seven months have
gone by what you're doing is not
working I need the man I'm married to
have a job at the local McDonald's at
Walmart shipping boxes at night I don't
care what it is but I need you to get up
every day with a
purpose or transition fully if y'all can
afford it to you are now a stay-at-home
Dad we stop daycare January
1 and that's
it because you have shown over the last
seven
months that you're really not interested
in getting a job he's probably waiting
for somebody to call him and say hey I
got a six figure met it's not gonna that
Call's not coming Call's not
coming and here's the weird thing I
don't know how it works or why it works
but he's if he is a six figure kind of
guy he'll start working at McDonald's
and he'll own three of them in the next
months I don't know how that works they
just
do he'll start working at Home Depot and
become a senior manager just because he
shows up and doesn't quit on people
right and and that's why part of the
reason I get get so frustrated it's cuz
he's so smart and he could do anything
it's just getting him to do
it yeah so when Dr Henry Cloud talks
about parents and their kids he talks
about what often people need in the
situation is they need some
problems like a kid if this was your 25y
old kid they would need to move out or
they would need to start paying
rent and so I think there has to be some
level of hey honey you're making this
choice and so on behalf of the family
we're going to start making these I'm
going to start making these choic I got
to protect these kids from thinking this
is what being a dad looks
like I've got to protect me because I
want to be married to you and I just am
losing respect in you because you lay on
the couch all
day is that fair are you are you there
I'm there I'm there I'm there for you
I'm there for you I just have such a
clear picture of a man that wouldn't
clean toilets in my church building and
dude I'll respect him till the end of
time right and I'm with you you know I
would I I've lost a job before right and
I went back out and got another one
immediately right and I know the job
Market's different and all that um it's
just and I I listen you took a call on
the Ramsay show a couple days ago and
you called the guy out and it was like
you're just making excuses and I was
like oh man that's my husband it's like
well I can't do this and I can't you
know and I was just
like that's what it is it's all it is
have you told him honey I I don't
respect you
anymore I haven't no okay I think that
we may be at a place where honesty is
important I love
you but I've watched you become a shell
of who you
were because you've lost purpose and if
your purpose isn't professional then my
God let your purpose be me let your
purpose be our kids let your purpose be
you but now it's become just a way of
life it's become a wallow and let's be
honest why would he get up right right
you aren't starving you still sleep with
him occasionally it's you don't have to
mess with his kids at all he gets to
play he gets to play uh fortnite you
know with kids on the other side of the
world in the middle of the I I don't
know what he's doing what does he do all
day he he's supposedly sitting at his
computer applying for jobs I mean he
does chores he's picked up a lot of the
laundry and he does chores you know
what's so scary about the way you said
that and I knew is coming you are
transitioning to his
mother right because he is a child he's
a
child and everybody out there let me
just say if you have a six-figure job
and you've got this big identity and you
get fired they lay you off of course you
take a couple of weeks to recalibrate of
course what just happened I'm calling my
contacts I'm going to have cups of
coffee with people and then go do a
thing go do a
thing go get a job are you going to be a
career server no but go get a job begin
to give yourself something that you have
to wake up for you have to shower for
you have to greet other
people and that will help clear the
cobwebs that helps rattle you like
through your
bones get up and go get them
man and for those of you stuck with
somebody who is becoming a deadbeat or
who is one or who is always scheming
well I got a plan I don't want to work
at that place cuz they make me work late
sometimes I don't want to work over
there because they
have have the hard conversation and tell
the
truth it's hard for me to be attracted
to somebody that won't
work I've lost respect in you for seven
months for one year for five years
you've sat here and waited for a phone
call for the quote unquote perfect
job you sit at your computer all
day and I drive by sign after sign after
sign saying Help want it help want it
help want
it go get a
job and apply at your computer after
we're all in after the kids are in bed
after I'm in bed then spend your time
dreaming in front of the
computer go get a
job if you lose a job that's powerful
and important to you yes there's going
to be a season of grief yes no question
about it I'm not callous I'm not an
idiot I've grieved jobs that I've
left but you got to go to work you got
to go to
work I'm so sorry and thanks for the
call let me know how that conversation
goes that's a that's a nuclear option
telling your husband you don't you don't
respect
him I think that's where we are we'll be
right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone this time of year
there could be be a lot of anxiety and a
lot of drama but it can also be great
but it can also be a mix of everything
right especially when it comes to giving
gifts maybe your family makes super
thoughtful handmade things or they
expect you to spend a million dollars or
maybe you just like experiencing time
together or pick up random gift cards
last minute things like gift giving can
make us bananas so no matter how hectic
it gets especially around giftgiving
remember to take care of yourself
whether it's going easier on yourself
during tough moments or having to say
hey we don't have enough money to buy
all these gifts or treating yourself to
a Day of Silence remember to give
yourself some love this holiday season
and if things get too heavy if thinking
about dealing with your family and all
of the drama gets to be too much give
better help a try better help is
flexible because it's online so it can
fit into your busy holidays schedule
just fill out a short questionnaire to
get match with the licensed therapist
and you can switch therapist at any time
for no extra charge in this season of
Chaos in love and sadness and all of it
rolled up to one give yourself what you
need with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com dealone toay to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com all right let's go out to
Michigan and talk to Michael what's up
Michael hey Dr John thank you for taking
my call and for your time of course man
thanks for calling in what's what's up
man how can I help so how do I deal with
my insecurities about my wife making
three times the amount of money I do and
also having a clear career Vision when I
don't what are you insecure
about I guess it's more so like I just
feel like a
leech it's your
wife like I'm just sitting here thinking
I would do I would love it if my wife
made three times what I
make that'd be incredible so I I I I'm
I'm struggling with that it tells me
there's something beneath the money
question you feel like a leech does she
make you feel that
way no no not at all um and we're we're
pretty recently newly wet
so we're trying to figure that all out
and everything but so you're bringing
bro you're bringing some ego into
this which is funny because I don't
think I have an ego because I can't
stand myself but you know well why can't
you stand
yourself oh that's for a whole another
call nope this that's this call why
don't why can't you stand
yourself
um I I can't stand how indecisive I am
about dang near everything in my life um
and
I don't know when I just when I just
kind of look at myself I'm just not
happy with what I
see what in the world does your wife
find Value
in um well she really loves the fact
that um you know I love my family and
then I'm family oriented um bull crap
bull crap on a stick you know what she
loves what
you
you dude when she said I
do she told God and you and your
families and your
friends ride or die till death till one
of us dies I'm
in and you immediately thought to
yourself I'm a
burden does your wife make a habit of of
lying of being
dishonest no no okay then why do you
think she's lying
now
uh I don't know here's the thing it's
all wound up together and here's why
um there's always the occasional
baseball player who is on
Deck and the guy up at bat hits the
game-winning
hit and everybody goes crazy and the
crowd cheers and everybody's jumping up
and down and he kind of feels like I
wanted to get the game when he
hit right that guy kind of sucks you
know why because they won the team
won yeah yeah and you're that guy
huh it's yeah I am and it's funny
because I preach to people that I've
coached all the time not to
be well yeah dude we we preach about I
think I wrote a book about anxiety
because that's what I that's what I
struggle with so
bad hey who who told you that you're not
worth even being married
to um a lot of
people name
them uh you know stupid High School
classmates that
would call me a school shooter just
because I didn't talk much okay who
else
um I guess you know
every every girl that I had
relationships with that for one reason
or another didn't care for me
and decided to leave okay who
else
I mean those are the two big ones that I
can think of they can't be because
you're not going to let a bunch of
moronic high school kids speak into your
marriage you're not going to let old
girlfriends speak into your
marriage what about Mom and
Dad um they're good mom was Mom's
interest thing but she loves me
and um my dad is I would say my best
friend have you ever asked your dad hey
dad do you love
me
um maybe a couple times when I was
younger I want you to call him and ask
him that
today okay I want you to ask him Hey Dad
are you proud of me
what would he say if you asked
that I think he would would say yes I'm
very proud of you
okay so it seems like your dad loves
you God he's proud of you and your
wife's all
in so what is this ego this
facad this big scary painting you
painted over the entryway that is your
Soul what is that protecting you from
high school
kids old girlfriends what's that
protecting you
from I don't
know it sounds like it's protecting you
from feeling like you're not
enough yeah yeah I would say that that's
accur I really know how to put that into
words what do you do for a living
um I'm currently working in
Academia well God that's why you hate
your life just
kidding that's what I did forever look
who's talking about hey I got out homie
I'm a YouTuber now fair enough um like
what do you what do you do in Academia
are you a professor are you an
administrator what do you do um so I'm
like an academic adviser for student
athletes okay so you're surrounded by
smart people you're surrounded by tons
of of performers you're surrounded by
unimaginable amounts of
ego and you make $32,000 a
year yeah yeah right right and everybody
asks you on a daily basis what are you
going to do what are you going to do you
get your Masters why haven't you get
your Masters yet when are you going to
get your PhD why you and you begin to go
I don't even know if I like it here what
do you
what yeah and then this one kid comes in
who can jump over over your head
standing still and do a backflip and
dunk a basketball and he won't even go
to math class and you're like
bro the god of the universe handed you a
Willy Wonka ticket and you won't even
cash it in he's like I ain't going to
class right right
yeah dude I spent some time with
academic advisors I know listen yeah
listen
they don't get a
vote the high school kids don't get a
vote I'm gonna say something crazy your
old man doesn't get a
vote your wife
does yeah a couple of close personal
friends and I want you to begin to this
going to sound so cheesy dude just trust
me on
this when you start to feel less than or
pissed off or angry or I don't even know
what I'm doing or when someone's like
why you're not getting a masters and
you're like no cuz I have 14 other
academic advisers I work with who all
have Masters in $48,000 in student loan
debt and they all make
$35,000 a year well I'm one of those
stupid people I got a master's and a
degree I
did even better I have it listen in the
last month how many people have asked
you about your PhD 10
five five exactly listen that's
Insanity yeah and I want you to do
something for me not for me forget that
do it for you I want you to make a fist
with your hand and just just gently rest
it on your chest and think out
loud they don't get a
vote they don't get a
vote and then you have to ask yourself
the terrifying question of what do I
actually want to do what kind of world
do I want to
build what life do me and my wife want
to have what do we want to feel like
when I get home when she gets
home hey honey how can I best freaking
love you
today what do we want to build
together because here's what you're
doing you're competing with her because
competition is the only way you know how
to
survive because you had a pretty lonely
run of it growing up didn't
you yeah
yeah and so all you know how to do to
stay a float is to look to your right
and to look to your left and make sure
everybody's heads are bobbing about the
same and then you married an amazing
woman who loves you and you look over
and you're looking like like at her Belt
Line because she's so much she's out of
the water more than you
financially but I bet you bring some joy
to her life that she doesn't have
otherwise I hope so I know so she
wouldn't have married you ding-dong
she's too smart she makes a lot of money
yeah right yeah you're right right so
what do you want to do what do you like
about academic
advising I do like when I kind of see
that light bulb go off in a kid's eye
was the same way when I was coaching
basketball where I finally see you know
the fruits of the labor of what I'm
teaching start to show itself why don't
you coach basketball
anymore um
I had a job last year where I was and it
didn't pay quite enough so I left
okay but that's that's a job that I
really do love were what level were you
coaching
at uh I was at High School varsity and
then before that I was at uh small
division three okay and it just couldn't
cover the
bills no yeah
okay
my first job out of college was a high
school basketball coach you know that I
did not know that I did that for two
years it's one of my favorite jobs I've
ever had yep I love the camaraderie with
my fellow coaches I was the youngest guy
by 10 or 15 years they treated me like a
son brother and I loved
them and I love my athletes and my
teammates and I love the guys the men
Troy kite and Mike Gibson and those guys
and Coach Perkins who helped raise me
right yeah like my first job and they
handed us a sheet of paper that says in
41 years here's what how much money
you're going to make and I said I'm out
right couldn't do it nope and I went to
grad school and got a degree that I did
not use I'm not using
now right but here's the light that
never went
out I love sitting with people who are
hurting I love seeing people take that
next right step
yeah and I've been a high school teacher
I've been a university administrator
I've been AA students I've been a
professor and now I'm I don't even know
what to call what I do
now here's the thing the job has been
the same and when I went backwards I
worked at Burger King for many years and
I loved it when people came in a little
bit deaded a little bit exhausted and I
was able to say dude how are you and
they would light up just for the human
interaction here's why I'm telling you
this there's a whole bunch of jobs you
can go do that will light up other
people yeah is that fair no that's yeah
that's absolutely fair and if you're a
guy who loves
coaching almost every business on planet
Earth needs you in their building right
now almost
everybody because people don't know how
to work together for a common goal
people don't know how to say hey are you
okay people don't know how to how to
understand hey if they're not okay
nutritionally and they're not okay at
their home they're not going to be okay
at work we need leaders who know how to
do that that's you
brother thank you you could go get a job
at
Dillard's you could go get a job as a
mid manager at a fill-in the
blank you could take the next three
years and this is what I did working at
a university getting tuition
reimbursement and got another degree in
in mental health
counseling and the school paid for it
you could go do anything man you know
why because you're a coach and you love
people
yeah but here's what I want you to do
with your
wife okay I'm GNA call her Susie okay
okay I hope that's not her name if
you're like dude how did you know that'd
be
awesome I want you to how long have you
been
married
officially two weeks how are you
unofficially
married all right so two weeks well it's
a long story all right yeah um it's a
long story and a short show so here's
the deal I want you to take her
out okay and I want you to um preferably
for breakfast or for lunch and here's
why when you p take take people out for
dinner the lights Get Low people get
kind of tired you have a glass of wine
when you take someone out for breakfast
it's sunny outside and there's just an
optimism and a light to the conversation
it can't happen at your house you have
to go somewhere okay and I want you to
reach across the table and hold her
hands and say you may not know this but
I've been competing with you for who
brings the most into this marriage and
I'm
sorry I've never had a ride or dive
partner until you and I'm going to
practice
being a great partner back but I don't
know how until I'm going to have to
practice I want you to say those
words and she's going to go oh my gosh
what are you talking about and be like
well you make way more than me she's
gonna say I promise I don't
care is that what she's gonna say y yeah
and you go I know but I do right now and
I know it's silly because I know all the
money goes in our same checking account
and we're both on the same
team but I want to feel like I'm
contributing
to and then I want you all to have a
discussion about the home you want to
build not the house not the architecture
but we want our house to feel like
this and maybe we want to have kids
someday and that gives us three years
for me to go get another degree or get
some more training or go get another job
outside of the academy which is just
chaos right now or whatever it
is but I want you to invite your wife
into probably the first time of your
life I want you to invite her into I
feel like I'm competing with you I feel
like I'm not enough and let her speak
into it and then say it's hard for me to
believe but I'm going to practice
trusting
you and when you see me feeling less
less than when you just grab my hand
hold my
hand when I feel less than I'm going to
be honest with
you I'm going to get my butt out there I
want you to hang on the line I'm get my
butt out there and start finding a job
that actually aligns with who I want to
become um by the way academic advising
amazing you got to have that job kids
come in from all over the world they
don't know up from down or how to
navigate the insanely stupid higher ed
system you got to have academic
advisors uh I want you to hang on the
line I'm going to send you the get clear
um assessment from my friend Ken Coleman
it's an assessment you work through that
will guide you into jobs that you may
not have ever thought about that take
into the things that you were wired to
do that will give you purpose and you
can make a whole bunch of money make a
whole bunch of
money I'm grateful for you
brother whenever you start to dut your
wife I want you to ask yourself quietly
has she ever lied to me before no she's
probably not lying now it's probably my
body trying to keep me
safe for the first time in my life I'm
safe now and when somebody asks you what
about that PhD man if you keep working
in four years you're going to be an
senior assistant director and with the
potential track to go to an associate I
want you to put your hand in your chest
and just go they don't get a vote they
don't get a vote they don't get a vote
and if in 5 years you're still at the
University great good if that's where
you want to be awesome I spent almost 20
years there I loved it but it may not be
for you and that's all
right we when anyone asks you the
question what are you worth the answer
is never a
number the answer is who do I love and
who loves me and you my brother are well
well loved
we'll be right
back hey it's deloney and the holidays
are coming up and holidays can be
stressful have you ever found yourself
hiding in a closet from all the chaos
and the noise and the political opinions
or been sitting in your car with your
hands gripping the steering wheel just
looking up to the sky saying why God why
I know you have and I have too so I'm a
Christian guy and listen regardless of
where you find yourself in the Christian
faith through tradtion you can find
peace with hallow the number one
Christian Prayer app on planet Earth
hallow has Christmas prayers and
meditations this holiday season Bible
stories and peaceful holiday music to
help you de-stress While You Work Shop
drive or hang out with family which are
times you probably need peace the most I
even listen to some of the music while I
work out their pre25 challenge offers
daily devotions based on the writings of
CS Lewis and these writings are voiced
by by Liam niss or you can listen to
scripture read by Jonathan roomy from
The Chosen and you can get hallow free
for 3 months at hall.com
dealone find peace for free for three
months at hall.com
dealone all right we are back hey for
this next segment um I have a pretty
cool um pretty cool
gift my friend Dr Uma Naidu
she is I'm going to read this she's a
nutritional
psychiatrist a Harvard trained
psychiatrist that focuses on the impact
of food and mental and emotional health
okay um she founded and directed the
first hospital-based nutritional
Psychiatry service in the US she's a
director of nutritional and lifestyle
Psychiatry at jmass at Massachusetts
General Hospital a very famous hospital
and she's also on the faculty at Harvard
Medical School here's her expertise her
expertise is the mechanics of how what
we eat impacts our physical and
psychological health and really our
emotional health if you're if I get
really granular about it but for the
sake of your souls we didn't get super
nerdy we didn't go down all the
mechanistic convers like like just super
nerdy here's what we talk about what
should you actually eat are you sick of
it you got to be robbed vegan I was I
told her during the interview I was
scrolling their day and someone was like
oatmeal will kill you oh my gosh you got
to eat all meat and be like what are we
doing as my friend Dr Norton says we
step over $100 bills to pick up nickels
when it comes to nutrition and so
finally not finally I've had several
guests on the show she is yet another
great guest talk about what are we
supposed to
eat she's got a brand new book out calm
your mind with food calm your mind with
food and it's it's a discussion of the
connection between anxiety and what we
eat I mentioned it briefly in my book um
this this connection between what we eat
and how our body
responds ah so much here so in the space
of a
call Dr Naidu and I unpack some things
well actually she unpacks it I asked her
some questions and she just runs with it
because she's brilliant so after uh
Thanksgiving and Christmas where if
you're like me you got off the
rails Dr naid is here to help taking you
into the new season I'm going to tell
you spoiler alert you're going to go
that's
really and the answer is yes we've made
things way way way too complicated
here's my conversation with Dr Uma
Naidu it was good to talk to you again
uh
man I've done a million uh Instagram
lives and I've not had the the feedback
that I got from our last conversation so
I'm glad that you are able to join me on
the show that's so fantastic thank you I
appreciate that you have a great
audience and uh clearly Theon stuff that
we talk about which is awesome I don't
know I don't know anybody who is not
just thrown their hands up and said I
quit when it comes to was I scrolling
the other night on Instagram which I'm
not supposed to do but I was
and I ran across one goofball saying
oatmeal will be the death of you it's
the worst thing you can put in your body
um somebody else saying that protein is
overrated you shouldn't have so much
protein somebody else say it's just
Madness and when you act Madness so I
feel let me say it like this I I feel
one of the greatest honors of my life is
I have friends like you in spaces that
live in this data and I'm able to pick
up a phone and say hey walk me through
this real quick but
99.999% of the US population doesn't
have access to people like you right and
so what happened what happened with our
food conversation that got so sideways
that there's people on one side saying
eggs are bad and somebody over here is
saying if you eat meat you're going to
all be dead and somebody else saying
know oatmeal will kill you and then
somebody else saying no you got to eat
protein or your body doesn't work right
what are what are we supposed to do how
did this happen it's yeah well I think
it happened because well there's there's
definitely been an explosion I'm sure
you'll agree with everything that went
online over Co right and prior to that
we were already a mixed Nation Eat This
Not That you know seeing things as just
categories of food versus what about
just moving from the standard American
diet called sad for a reason to just a
Whole Foods diet as best we can it's not
perfect but as many Whole Foods I also
feel like uh people make these
statements for um to enhance their
followers and to enhance engagement and
all this trickery which hey you know
what you want to build your Instagram
following you go do you but provide the
public with well readed information for
example oatmeal oatmeal can be
complicated a JN because sometimes the
prepackaged oatmeal can be loaded with
lots of sugar and stuff that we don't
really need a version of oatmeal can be
healthier and a good grain for you to
eat but should you be eating it every
single day maybe not because continuous
glucose monitoring studies and research
you show that it does actually hit your
metabolic Health it's not always the
healthiest food in the way that it's
claimed to be and the way it's marketed
now does that mean it's evil no that
means have your oatmeal make it in a
healthy way you know add in a a good
source of milk or whatever you're doing
be mindful of your toppings and don't
have it it for every single day mix it
up with Cher pudding and eggs and all
sorts of things but the conversation has
gotten very toxic and I find it uh I'm
often dealing with the aftermath of
people coming and saying well I I was
told I should never eat a a a bean and
someone else saying I have to go
plant-based because I'm hearing if I eat
meat it's going to kill me so
it's it's a lot of confusion out there
and hard to sort through you just said
it sorry for interrupting you just said
it something that I want everyone to
hear and
um I've become close friends with
several folks in the nutritional space
who have degrees they have pedigree here
and they know what they're talking about
and behind closed doors when I ask him
like Hey why do you keep why do you keep
going after people it's what you just
said because they end up in the hospital
they end up with completely deranged
metabolic systems they they end up with
completely deranged um um I don't want
to get too nerdy but their body start
falling apart and they're just trying to
do the best thing that somebody told
them and so kudos to you for saying whoa
whoa whoa whoa here's actual data here
is like and you're not just somebody
you're not just like a nerd like me who
sits in a room and writes books you also
see patience you also build programs
that have efficacy to them like you're
not just an influencer trying to get a
following it sounds like you are at the
at the end receiving line in a hospital
with these folks and you're tired of
seeing hurting people and so if we can
move Upstream so I'm just so grateful
thank you it all lands on this I want
You're Gonna Save Us all right now okay
and I know I I don't I don't give any
spoiler alerts uh spoilers in your book
I want everyone to pick up calm your
mind with food so picture in your mind a
single mom with three kids and she's
just been buying a bag of of offbrand
Cheerios and that's what her kids have
for breakfast and she gives them skim
milk cuz she heard that full fat milk's
bad for him or the Over The Road Trucker
who is puts on five or 10 pounds every
year who just wants to be a little more
present father he's got a little more
energy wants to slowly begin to to to
give his kids a
picture what would you just outline as
big
picture what should they eat
some basic principles basic principles
go yes some go towards actually have six
pillars of nutritional Psychiatry which
I outlined in my first book and and some
of the pillars are the following eat the
whole food and skip the processed
version of it so whatever I mean by that
eat an orange skip the stought orange
juice which has all the fiber removed
and added sugars which you don't need
but if you eat the orange it has all the
micronutrients you need it is fresh
delicious and has vitamins as well the
more times we can keep that mind that
principle in mind the better you can
have frozen broccoli you can get
broccoli in the uh fresh produce section
or cauliflower or you can have the
highly processed version that's added to
a nugget or um some kind of you know
trickery that the food company has come
up with to sell that broccoli to you as
a healthy product unfortunately even if
the broccoli is okay it's loaded with a
lot of stuff that your body doesn't need
and what I'm referring to are the
colorance of Dy the food stabilizers Etc
that you don't need and that's what goes
into processed foods and research has
shown in animals that when we consume
things like thickeners called CMC
carboxy meal cellulose from uh foods
that are thickened with it for example
that it is damaging and disruptive to
the gut microbiome in animal studies and
in fact leads to short lower production
of short chain fatty acids something
that we want our gut microbes to be
helping us produce that's healthy for us
that that fends off information
and other discomfort in the gut so we
know this and what we want to be doing
is just going as much as possible for um
for for Whole Foods when we can
difficult to avoid processed food but
what you choose makes a difference um
another thing is lean into the the the
leafy greens because wherever you can
get your B vitamins think brain B
vitamins because many of the B vitamins
if not all of them are involved in brain
health vitamin B12 from different animal
proteins or nutritional yeast vitamin B9
from leafy greens folate low folate is
associated with the low mood that's a
good one for you so I say add in those
leafy greens and have your nutritional
Psychiatry plate mostly loaded with
colorful vegetables for the fiber the
micronutrients that you're going to get
and and all the things that your body
needs then choose your clean protein you
may want a nice piece of beef you may
want a piece of tofu whatever your
dietary preference is make sure the best
version that you can get that's
accessible to you then add in your
healthy fats and a smaller portion of
say a whole grain like kinma or whatever
it is that you prefer so in other words
you're not you don't have a pile of
kinma you have a small serving of it but
you really filling your plate with
satiating vegetables which are complex
they are carbohydrate but complex they
break down more slowly this is a simple
thing if we think about it we can adjust
in every single plate that we eat or
what we cook um so it's going back to
those principles and then add in spices
and herbs because they're rich in
antioxidant and anti-inflammatory
properties they're pretty much calorie
free they're saltree and sugar-free if
you just buy a spice you know from the
from the supermarket and you can flavor
up your food to make them make whatever
you're eating super delicious so those
are just some jumping off points for
people to try and don't forget water
hydration is extremely important and
dehydration worsens depression and makes
people anxious
so so tell me if I if I'm smiling
because um I had a buddy about a decade
ago he's since passed away but about a
decade ago he said the Arc of nutrition
and Physiology
exercise is heading towards something
that is going to be very challenging to
package and sell and I said what you
mean by that and it
continues like how do you get in great
physical shape well walk most of the
time or do some zone two and have a
Sprint day and lift weights several
times a week Tada and as my buddy Dr
Norton says people often trip over $100
bills to pick up nickels we want it to
be so complex and similarly we have so
many fat diets and so much this and so
much this and so much this and what
you're saying is hey eat whole real
foods the way nature invented them right
and get make sure you get enough fiber
and good vegetables and make sure you
get good proteins and have a little fun
along the
way it can't be that easy but just is
it so I think I think this is this is
where it gets hard it gets hard with the
the different type of messaging that's
out there like you mentioned the oatmeal
issue yeah and it also gets difficult
because I I fundamentally do believe
people know what healthier foods are but
it's inconvenient they're often stressed
and in a rush to get food on the table
make sure that the family is fed make
sure that you know um that there are
choices that that Everyone likes and I
think unfortunately we get you know we
we start to eat processed food in our
brain gets trict into liking it because
the processed foods are engineered to be
hyper palatable to tap out Cravings if
you've ever ordered french fries at a
fast food drive-thru you're often upsize
and when you're upsized you eat the
whole bag and then the next day you're
like H maybe I want some more um you're
a healthy guy maybe that's not happen
but it happens to a lot I would have I
would have I would have french fries
every day yes multiple times they're so
they're so good and and and here and
here's the thing uh they are delicious
but they in a fastwood rest they
actually often have added sugar that you
don't taste but they've been engineered
to be so tasty and yummy that we want
more and our brain then wants it again
so these are these are the things that
that we're working against and what we
what I'm saying is that it there's it's
much more nuanced than what I'm sharing
right now and the nuances are in the
book you know what are the different
spices you want to incorporate for
anxiety what the different herbs that
are possible which teas are best but for
basic principles it it's not it's so
easy it's more that we've almost lost
our way and people have this this
messaging which gives them more
confusing information and when they have
just a plate of food in front of them
they think it can't be this you know and
I feel like part of it is also making
that habit change because we often
choose foods out of convenience and it's
harder to make those homecooked meals
and do the shopping and prepare because
we're all so busy but research has even
shown that you know when we prepare PR
meals at home and we eat more meals at
home we lose weight and we consume pure
calories so this is helpful information
for us to know yeah it's incredible well
thank you so so much for joining us um
all the way from are you in Boston
now I'm actually in New York today
because I had an event here so very cool
well thank you for making time for us
and for audience and um we will link to
your book and um I wish you the absolute
best um just some quick advice to you
dear during your book um your book
launch week make sure you eat lots of
leafy green vegetables and clean I'm
just kidding hey I'm really really
grateful for you you're so you're so
generous with your time but I wish you
the absolute best sell a million copies
thank you thank you
doc hey what's up delone here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
alone.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
we're going with a
classic written by somebody who I think
most everybody would be okay if she
would just decide to run for
president maybe supreme leader of Earth
and ship this shape up this ship is that
how you say
it not you don't ship up this shape you
shape up this ship get things in order
the great and
awesome and Powerful Dolly Parton
singing her classic 9 to5 tumble out of
bed and I Stumble to the kitchen I pour
myself a cup of
ambition and yawn and stretch and try to
come to life jump in the shower and the
Blood starts pumping out on the streets
the traffic starts jumping the folks
like me on the job from 9 to
5: working 9 to five what a way to make
a Liv And barely getting by it's all
taken and no given they just use your
mind and they never give you credit it's
enough to drive you crazy if you let
[Music]
it Dolly run for president please we
need you see you later guys stay in
school don't do drugs
[Music]